welcome back school closures kids
learning at home and parents taking on
teacher roles no problem a new online
resource is bringing parents and
educators together to help them with at
home learning during this unprecedented
challenge so take a look at this the
COBIT nineteen pandemic forced
nationwide school closures for parents
grappling with work from home and
managing their children's educational
needs hang in there I think the
important thing is to just trust your
instincts our kids learn not only at
school but they really do learn
everywhere and what they're gaining at
this time are not only us from skills
but also they're building independence
and resilience maybe even more so than
their parents parent teachers you are
not alone there is free help online
what's beautiful about the learn
everywhere Facebook group is that
parents offer up questions and then what
you'll see is that hundreds of other
parents provide their ideas their
solutions links to resources tips
information you name it you have
hundreds of parents providing support
and guidance so we've taken all of that
information collected it and made it
easy to find on a companion website
called learn everywhere dot-org again
that's learn everywhere org